miranda lambert earliest her seventh
studio album today called wild card
which comes three years after her double
album the weight of these wings which
got huge acclaim and dominated the
Country Music Awards that year yeah
after she released seven of wildcards
tracks as previews before today
including the official single it all
comes out in the wash we get the whole
fourteen song album today and the
reviews are stellar
Rolling Stone says Miranda Lambert's
wild card is a freewheeling country rock
masterpiece it's the sound of a
freewheeling star at the top of her game
reimagining rock history in her own
platinum image The Guardian gives it
four out of five stars saying the
Tennessee Stars seventh album is a
robustly entertaining set of drol
country songs about men boozed and doing
the laundry and sounds like Nashville
roped Lambert is as bold and fearless as
fans revere her for while still honoring
her vulnerable side that allows her to
keep her heart open even in the darkest
hours continuing her reign as one of
country music's most important artists
pitchfork loves a2 saying Wild Card is
fun as hell Lambert sounds relaxed
playful happy and comfortable throughout
Lambert celebrates the multitudes of
being a hot mess prioritizing the joy of
personal growth / lamenting the pitfalls
and potholes and finally taste of
country said in their review it might be
possible for Lambert to sound
inauthentic but she hasn't shown it yet
in her nearly 15 years of releasing
records perhaps her most
underappreciated quality is a dedication
to truly making an album feel like more
than just a collection of songs and
that's what I love about her now Miranda
is no stranger to getting incredible
reviews for her album but in a preview
of Sunday today she says she still gets
scared before she releases new music you
still get nervous about that I don't
sleep for like three days before I put a
record out this one is less pain thank
the Lord I'm in a great place a lot of
my career has been built on sarcasm and
a little fire and so I'm kind of ready
to bring that back into the game there's
ups and downs but in my case it's just
public so sometimes it gets a little
rough but just because it's all out
there for everybody to hear and see you
know what I mean but so is happiness and
that's where I am right now I mean when
you're truly find someone that loves you
for who you are and that you genuinely
are smiling it's like it's it's not from
the inn
you know what I mean it's a lot that
kind of clicks on that you really didn't
know wasn't was off
he's pretty laid-back and friendly and
sweet and just like very go with the
flow kind of guy which is great for this
life because you kind of have to go for
the rope and I'm glad to share it with
him and that he's open to it and you
know definitely feels good to be singing
soon a few love songs let's not get
crazy I don't want to get too happy if I
can't write a sad song but it's funny to
us if talking with that if couple weeks
ago to like she's in a happy
relationship to and like she got worried
that I'm still be able to write all my
pain gone that's it as an artist right
there's looks fantastic songwriters that
know like office if ik is still there
she's an absolute Pro like in every part
of the industry right there's no doubt
that she would turn out a great product
but I mean the reviews are stellar
yeah keeps us happy for Miranda good
that she's in the news because of her
work and not her personal life mmm-hmm
my curious man is doing a clothing line
here in Texas and yeah that's the thing
like I've always been a huge Miranda
lamp frame but I'm always a fan of
artists that do great albums but if I
like someone they do a bad album I'm
fully overly prepared to call the road
they do bad album Miranda just keeps up
putting out like right now they have
great album yeah what do you think of
her releasing yes if we heard seven of
the songs before this album came out
which is the trend now like Ed Sheeran
did that with like probably seven of the
tracks
yeah like what do you think of that
obviously it's a whole like business the
way they just the way things go right
people want you get that song and you
want the next one you want this one you
want the next one some people will be
buying the song yeah that's the thing I
think Miranda's still established like
Ed Sheeran that like people are still
gonna get the album yeah
once it does come out so the one song
that I really like an album is holy
water
those listen to that's the one sänger
yeah yeah that's thing like so we
already heard half this album but yeah
they're still set another song stream
here oh I'm at they've got to give it a
listen haven't given those in there
alright for you though okay
yeah alright that's it for today we're
gonna leave you with Miranda singing
Bluebird offer new album the view we'll
see ya
[Music]
just
[Music]
keep a bluebird in my heart